now summertime for most americans
means more fun and freedom to do the
things they love
but for most democrats coast-to-coast
it's a time to just kind of
revel in being miserable or at least
make others miserable
and focus on how much they hate the
time-honored american traditions that
the rest of us love
so they'd rather define america solely
around the horrors of slavery
or the events like january 6th they kind
of want american school children to be
taught that
aside from the civil rights marches in
the 60s and a few
key milestones that were reached by
minorities
america is pretty much intrinsically
racist and evil
well look these are truly wretched
people who would put
trigger warnings on american flags if
they could people who
celebrated statues being ripped down
last year and
who wouldn't be caught dead at a fourth
of july parade this year
they'd rather nod along to the drones on
npr
or kvetch about how crummy life in
america
is so mingle with a bunch of americans
who
come out to celebrate their country
singing things like god bless america
never now case in point
one of the most loathsome figures on the
political scene today
freshman congresswoman from missouri
corey bush
she's an aoc acolyte and a bernie
sanders buddy commemorated our nation's
birthday by tweeting that black people
still aren't free
and then it's a holiday for white people
now
she is literally a sitting congresswoman
saying blacks aren't free
and then she refers to stolen land my
question to uh
congresswoman bush is should st louis be
given back to the native americans
does she even think about the absurdity
of all of these positions
of course not because as with her pals
in the squad like
elon omar and so forth bush's stock and
trade
is racial grandstanding now last
august when she won her primary against
long-time incumbent william clay
she hinted at revolution
we decided that we are going to wait any
longer for change and that
that change that isn't actually coming
we have the answers
if you didn't really understand what
happened what was birth
right here in saint louis missouri in
ferguson if you didn't understand
well what she hasn't shown us is that
she gives a damn about what's happening
in her own district
did you know that on thursday in an
eight
time span four children were shot there
unless you think that that was all in
one place no there were three separate
incidents
according to saint louis metro police
stats of the 97 homicide victims thus
far in 2021 in st
louis all but five were black victims
of the 44 identified suspects
all but five were black of course that
dynamic does not fit
corey bush's racist anti-cop narrative
so she simply ignores the facts and
sticks to america bashing which she
truly
loves and san francisco speaking of
cities in decline continues to be a
living hell
stores like target they can't even stay
open because crime is so bad there
luxury stores are being hit in broad
daylight no consequences
and of course you know you'll see this
video we counted 10 suspects
busting out of a neiman marcus all
carrying
the essential luxury good items
well expensive handbags who doesn't need
those and oakland's police chief
says that this fourth of july was among
the most violent he's
ever seen we're talking about 24
hours he said of non-stop chaos
so as americans of all backgrounds grow
disgusted by the biden
crime explosion the more desperate
democrats will become
to start looking for scapegoats
or to change the topic altogether so
they returned to the well
of january 6th where the only person
shot
was an unarmed protester we begin this
hour with the breaking news on those
horrific
new videos from january 6. look at all
their cell phones all their laptops you
have to
interview them interview their friends
maybe
the biggest fbi investigation ever
we've also seen the growing trend of
far-right extremism within the halls of
congress
it's a neo-fascism that we've not seen
in this country
more reflective of what we saw in the
1940s and 30s in a place called
germany so i i find great concern with
that
i find great concern with that this is
truly pathetic
of course obsessing on this faux
insurrection
isn't just a deflection effort on their
part
it's now become a pretext for the
democrats to do what they've always
wanted to do
to crack down on conservative activism
speech and conservative organizing
now we're going to tell you more about
pelosi's new police state later on in
the show
but if nancy wants her party to hold the
house she'd better do a better job
policing her own nut jobs
and of course disassociating herself
from the america hating activists
that she and her party have been
coddling
remember when we told you that it was
not just the american
of a confederate flag that they objected
to last year
it wasn't just the confederate monuments
that they objected to well
we told you that it was all a trojan
horse for what they
really wanted to take down america
herself starting with our national flag
there was this heartwarming news story
by new york times reporter sarah maslan
near
marlene rodriguez said that she once
regularly flew the flag at her home in
freeport
taking it down only in winter for safe
keeping but about three years ago
when spring came miss rodriguez who is
black and a democrat
left the flag in storage it hasn't come
out since
it felt like it didn't belong to me
anymore she said
and washington post columnist is that's
what you call him philip kennycott
celebrated july 4th by attacking lady
liberty
why not it is ambiguous and ambivalent
meaningless or foreign a symbol of
hypocrisy
or unfulfilled promises
then pbs they just oozed national unity
when during the national fireworks
display vanessa williams
sang the black national anthem
i dedicate this to my ancestors to our
new federal holiday
juneteenth lift every voice
[Music]
a beautiful woman and a beautiful voice
but come on this was
this was never about some
old monument to the confederacy it
wasn't about the flag the confederate
flag
it's about the ultimate hatred of the
left
of all things traditionally american and
then spreading that propaganda
that feeds ignorant comments like this
if you know your history you know the
full song of the national anthem
the third paragraph speaks to slaves in
america
our blood being slain and and filtered
all over the floor
it's disrespectful and it does not speak
for black americans
it's obvious there's no there's no
question
well there is a question what she said
was just false but just remember as much
as the left despises our country's
patriotic core
they've absolutely no problem with china
showing off
their national pride and they love how
efficient and insightful the ccp is
because look central authority that not
only restricts speech of the opposition
but then punishes anyone who strays in
word or deed
the once respected reuters published a
story previewing china's 100 year
anniversary
that read more like a ccp press release
she has cracked down on corruption that
eroded the party's moral authority
the party's ranks swelled by 2.43
million members in 2020 the biggest
annual increase since she became
president
a beijing resident gave a resounding yes
when asked if
she would like the party to stay in
power for another 100 years
as if that woman would dare say anything
else to an
american media outlet and expect to
survive the night come on
and rachel maddow doppelganger and msnbc
host chris hayes
he even found common cause with the
ccp's news agency on the issue of
american gun ownership
continue to be grimly fascinated by how
much america's truly exceptional levels
of gun violence
figure in the perception of the country
around the world
that is true chris because no country
better to be our moral arbiter than one
guilty
of widespread ethnic cleansing neto
well from soaring crime to racial
bullying the democrat
china crush it's tempting to revel in
the liberal
implosion that's happening right now and
it's tempting to focus
only on the political benefit to the gop
but i'm here to tell you tonight there
are real world effects
from their embrace of anti-americanism a
new fox news poll shows that
today only 69 percent of americans think
the us is the best country to live in
that's down from 84 when obama was
president the media was happy back in
2011.
our young people they're being bombarded
by the most
unbalanced skewed vision of america
both in the classroom and of course
celebrity stuff on social media
most have heard more about white
privilege than they have about world war
one
and it's having a corrosive effect
are you proud to be an american no
i feel embarrassed to be an american
every day
i think that's a complicated question
for me i think i i
i think most of the time know at least
over like the past four years
um it's been tricky to you know love to
be an american
half seas on that like partly because
like
i feel like there's certain topics where
it's like very controversial
but like i don't know i would honestly
rather kind of live somewhere else
well it's like the door is always open
it's like
bye that is truly terrifying all right
ultimately it's going to be up to
sane americans who can actually speak to
turn this around
the solutions aren't partisan they're
common sense
you cannot serve a country you loathe
you can't promote the values of a
country abroad that you loathe
and you certainly can't unite a country
you work so
feverishly to divide along racial ethnic
and class
lines but we're not going to turn this
around by just appealing to the red
states
new england needs to save itself and at
some point
the good people on the west coast are
going to grow tired of things like
rolling blackouts and high taxes
and of course skyrocketing crime it's
only a matter of time
and when that happens we could see a
wipeout of the liberal lunacy
that has made the past six months seemed
like six years
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else